kadi christie concentrez vous bien
concentrez vous entendrez aller dans une
espèce de
une tranche pas quelqu'un qui met en
transe de trouver ça ou dans un carton
de genre 95,7 les anciens proprio on
laisse au sous-sol zaho brf intense à
ryan white on est les frères fitch
qu'est-ce qu'il ya des bruits dans ma
chambre il ya des bruits dans ta chambre
d'accord on papa va monter pour voir si
c'est quoi
t'as vu ça il faut qu'on trouve les
autres cas c est mike mack la caméra
franchement il se passe des choses
étranges ici et là plus beau temps de
réglage
non j'y crois pas elle est pro grands
c'est bizarre je vois quelque chose
quand je regarde devant la caméra c'est
quoi ça je crois que cette caméra peut
voir des choses qu'on peut pas voir à
l'oeil nu
c'est incroyable j'ai entendu parler
d'esprit sur des photos mais perso j'en
ai jamais vu
qu'est ce que tu fais là dedans dit
bloody mary je sais pas ce qui se passe
mais ça a un rapport avec les cassettes
c'est la première fois que tu as in
quelque chose comme ça comment elle a pu
monter aussi haut
via cru qui est si quelqu'un est tout
fait qu'on s'installe dans cette maison
il n'y a pas de coïncidence je crois
qu'elle fait partie d'une prophétie
mike ne bouge pas de quelque chose
derrière toi